welcome to this video playing FM mata
leão from canada and it's a chi Goran
hmm okay yeah not really for years i'm
thinking i should look I should really
study at least one line against this
opening so that I can can get at least
something when I when I face it but I
tend to forget it and then I play
something like that which not really
looks like a serious try for an
advantage and okay the Chigi rain is not
entirely crazy bad but you should at
least try to get something a little
something and here it's not much black
only needs to address this still
somewhat misplaced knight on c6 and you
should be okay maybe night somewhere d 8
36 wow really well it's a bit of a
strange move looks very weakening anyway
how to how to play a lot clearer age
three this is hanging but it's not
really metering much
and 95 night takes bishop h5 is probably
not not helping at all ok I'm going to
take him this was possible anyway he can
of course get it get a pawn back on be
too but in general this shouldn't be a
great structure so how to do that Queen
a three evenings interesting would be
one yeah maybe rupee one it cannot
establish a rock long-term rock be a
time taking queen a three and he needs
to return
cairo queen here night a4 would be nice
but he will probably play with p8 now
okay I'm not guessing any move gayathri
is not bad not bad at all yeah trying to
get the play against my pawn him ok now
let's let's get a night to see five it's
not really so great
I for strong strong muth I was really
expecting them to take okay i put the
night there i'm not sure that it really
needs too much no I'm in a pin
hmm yeah to how to get any anywhere here
it's not easy Black has good pieces
active pieces and this is not exactly
great as well the sum square on g3 okay
hmm maybe I can get a technical trick in
okay yeah was here 95 was the trick I
wasn't thinking about with my deaf seven
but he am prevented that okay yeah each
wang's i would love to play 95 here but
he can just take it g4 Queen g3 is not
helping as well ok so maybe maybe
prepare it or something I'll get nigeria
nigeria okay look after we're done item
mind you just need to play this
Jim that's really not great
mmm night 95 is not really good here
okay no human moment just a moment isn't
there some stuff hanging here go here
isn't this a big overload
what is he doing now on threatening rook
f8 Queen f7 made nitey to check coveney
to look let's check mid checkmate I
think it was lost anyway but i don't i
can take f2 we can take f2 of course I
was thinking this one but he can take
care of course yeah and this is of
course not lost it it's okay for black
young it's okay if I would be able to
get the night over 25 and I'd be better
but I cannot do that 95 or stronger hmm
ok i was i was so hypnotized by the mid
thread 95 was Paterno came yeah because
I get the night there that's exactly the
point of course that's the point and he
cannot play this cake and then queen bee
five what a move ok computer chess yeah
the night only five I need to go to e5
that's the point ok and you should
probably just exchange everything off
him ok so the spoils it really checkmate
but you overlook the maid mm-hmm
interesting so this is the point they
are very very complicated i mean around
here I don't really think he has a good
opportunity which hear this one
check means I must play look everyone
here not exactly great yeah this was a
bit shaky around here f4 was strong this
was so I was strong even even if the
computer likes my position I don't I
don't really don't really think it's
that easy yeah around here also expected
him to take to sort of misplace my Ruca
and then yeah okay now is this position
where you can take yeah this wasn't good
at all this wasn't good at all okay
thanks for watching